beautiful young man huh that's by far
the best batman
spiderman oh yeah i got you
what's up it's your boy logan from the
318. oh damn
it's your boy larry from compton out of
louisiana we have a debate club for
y'all what's up larry
what is the real l.a the boot
or los angeles tell us what you think
los angeles
gang gang deez nuts
surprise ending bro yeah right so he's
saying los angeles
louisiana what's the real l.a you know
oh
who's from la though you know what i'm
saying yeah that's the point
who's from l.a no one's really friends
no one's really from here
louisiana but also people in louisiana
get the [ __ ] out as well
and they come to l.a
ladies in a tough time right now i'm
hating on la right now just because it's
there's bombs everywhere there's
protests
there's looting we got the gayest
governor in the world
it's gaffin well first of all what do
you get it for uh you were like a man
named gavin you name your son gavin
you're gonna have
problems gavin is your buddy who plays
baseball it's his little brother that's
over on the side of the field [ __ ]
sneaking snow cones and doing [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] oh that's gavin
gavin's the guy who steals money from
you you know what i'm saying like that's
a weird name
yeah i think i mean la proper is it's
just hollywood
and [ __ ] is the part of l.a that i i
forget sometimes
i just don't like the hollywood [ __ ] is
i think the thing that [ __ ] everything
up
because you go on like other podcasts
you go on like jk news or something and
those people it's all they're just
normal they sound like the same
things that we think about you know yeah
like it's just jk new that's a news site
it's um podcast right you guys know jk
just kidding news
yeah no it's like a youtube channel with
a bunch of asians and mexicans it's
hilarious
dude and yeah they it just like they're
just like regular
normal yeah it's just not like hollywood
[ __ ] hollywood [ __ ] but i see all the
celebs making that video
like working on we're not staying quiet
anymore
yeah and they look quiet
and also i assume everyone that video is
racist dude i'll [ __ ] somebody needs
to throw a harpoon through their window
but
you're right bro and we could probably
actually get i could get in trouble for
saying that
i think l.a the non-non-hollywood
la's great louisiana we're just on fire
right now
yeah and louisiana too also a lot of it
is canadians that they sent down there
yeah
really yeah a lot of canadian criminals
they sent down to louisiana
into the acadian areas and stuff like
that louisiana's that true blood hitter
though yeah
so i always ride with louisiana so you
got a lot of bootleg
canucks down there hiding doing canadian
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] dirty water but
louisiana ellen came from there who's a
[ __ ] so that's against you guys
yeah so we got a negative one uh
but what else came out of louisiana
purchase first of all you're welcome
about 17 states y'all owe us this was a
take responsibility look at all these
[ __ ] this is a parody that uh kyle
dunnigan did
who is [ __ ] hilarious
[Laughter]
i take responsibility for every
unchecked moment for every time i said
give me five
on the right hand side i'll take
responsibility for not listening to
megan
and leaving me knickers on the floor
they're called underpants i will no
longer allow an unchecked moment
i will no longer throw away the
african-american part of the oreo cookie
just to get to the creamy white milk
i will hire more black hookers voting
for a jog should not be a death sentence
sleeping
in your own home should not be a death
sentence
ah sorry i guess
we are no longer bystanders well who the
hell is that broad
racist murderous cops need
one the only time is going to stop
truly holding the perpetrators uh
to account start putting him in jail he
[ __ ] talked about it he killed
somebody
there this bill maher impression is
pretty dude
he's a beast that was very damn good
monster yeah
yeah sounded just like him that's
hilarious man i'm going to say louisiana
just because that's where i'm from dude
so yeah
you have to yeah the time was canadians
or mexicans my family's mexican i went
with canadians
i'll never live that oh yeah
my son sent me a long nasty email
he's emailing from the club too which is
crazy dude damn
yeah man he's at jimboree and he's
[ __ ] dropping all these emails
uh yeah i go louisiana man i'll stick
with the boot man
the kingdom